Next, I tried to use the ionic foot bath, the ion pro wave, and the device that goes into
the water wasn't lighted up when placed in the water. When I pulled it out, the blue light
would come on. So, okay, this is not a problem with the ion pro wave. It's a problem with
the computer. So, if you have a problem with your ion pro wave, something similar to this
that goes on, I took the water, it goes off, I take it out, it goes on again. It is a Microsoft
update issue. So, you don't want to run Microsoft updates. You should not have your computer
connected to the internet. Make sure that your computer is on airplane mode. So, it's not
trying to run Microsoft updates. But the solution to this is that you boot the computer down
and you do what's called a hard boot of your computer. Meaning, go to the power button
on your computer, hold it down for 10 seconds until the computer completely turns off. Wait
about five minutes, then come back, now turn the button, push the button on again, allow
it to do a full reboot. That should fix the problem. If you have problems with it, after
that, make sure you're called Micah truerife. And there could be something wrong, but that
is 99 out of 100 times it's a Microsoft issue. So, we just need to do a reboot of the computer.